- People need people who listen.
- People need people and then
people need people that
listen and then people
need people that
listen and do something.
("Lazy Lover" by Common Souls)
- [Claude] When
I was a kid I wanted to
be a philanthropist
and a movie director
but what I realized was that I
wanted to help people back then.
Way back in those days.
My job is to have
relationships with the people
that I work with
and that I work for.
The difference between
values and strengths
as well as the difference
between strengths and skills.
And so I work for 700+ people,
I work with 700+ people.
I have a wonderful team
that also services 700+ people.
Any other relationships,
there's a ton
but I'd love to just hear
some of them between skill,
strength, values.
- [Sam] I put home
for values because
I think that, you
talk about this a lot,
that you want everyone to
feel when they come to work
to feel like they're in a place
that's comfortable for them,
safe space.
Home I feel like is a word that
means a lot of these things.
It means empathy,
it means inclusion,
it means trust,
you go home and
that's where you're safe.
- Yep.
- [Sam] I feel like we
have a responsibility to create
a home here if we can.
- Yeah.
I, 1000% agree.
DRock was asking me today
what my morning routine is
and so I was
telling him about it
which is probably
boring to you guys
so I won't tell you about it.
(group laughter)
But a lot of the
times I prep myself,
I might, if I'm talking to
my best friend on the phone
or if I'm listening to music,
I'm prepping
myself to literally
make space so that we can
make people feel safe
physically and
psychologically safe
every single day to
be their best selves.
That's it. That is
my number one mission.
That's what Sam
was talking about
in terms of making
people feel at home
or creating a home
for 600, 700 people.
But what that means to me is
to have belief in 700+ people
no matter what happens.
I think the belief in
people and understanding that
people are
choosing to be at Vayner
for a very specific reason.
They could go to any
of the other agencies,
which are wonderful,
but people choose to come here,
I truly believe,
because of the culture
and because of the exceptional
work that we've been doing.
The past 20 years that
I've spent in agency life
has taught me how to be agile.
Taught me how to
embrace change and risk
and it's taught me
how to seek knowledge
from all people and arenas.
It's taught me how to read a
room and stay ahead of the curve
and on the right
side of history rather
than paddling
against the current.
So when I say,
"How do we light people up?"
This is a big
question for us because
we are serving other people
and we work for the greater.
This is my question to
myself every single day
which is how do I light
you guys up? You know?
I have something up
in my room right now
which says,
"How do you light people up?"
And I keep it
there for a reason.
I keep it there to see
how many people look at that
white board when they come
in and does that inspire them.
So I'd like to think
I'd light people up all day.
If I do it half a day,
I'm lucky, right?
I believe Gary
lights people up all day.
I believe you
light up people all day.
I want to know how many people
look at that
white board and think,
"How can I light
someone else's day up?"
How can I light them up?
It's not all about me.
How can I light
someone else's day up?
That's what we do.
I know what my
purpose is every single day
when I come in to work and I
know what my purpose is in life
so I can use all of
that passion to say,
"Hey Justin, come on, what do
you want to do? Let's do this."
Know what I mean?
Jo Beth, what
do you want to own?
- [Jo Beth] I think
the fact that she trusts me
and the team to do what
she knows that we'll do
the best job ever at
is inspiring for me
to go out and kill it every day.
- We are family
and beyond a family,
we are friends.
There's such a camaraderie here
and to come into the door
and feel it is like nothing else
every single day.
It's magical.
- So the hard thing about
actually working with Claude is
that she teaches you and
everybody around you
something every single day.
- [Claude] The relationship
I then get to have with them
is feeling like
I got the golden ticket.
I get to sit with them and
listen to them and
watch them grow.
That's like the
biggest honor in the world.
- [Gary] So as of today,
starting on Monday,
we now have a
Chief Heart Officer. Alright?
And that Chief Heart Officer
is actually here.
So I think we should
grab our Chief Heart Officer.
(audience applause)
("Bandaids Pt. 2"
by Common Souls)
- [Sam] I think my
favorite Claude moment
was when she was
introduced as CHO
'cause she had
been here previously,
obviously as an
SVP and when
Gary introduced
the name of the role,
everyone kinda started
to like buzz a little bit
and then as she
rounded the corner
and just kind of
raised her hands in the air,
we were all cheering for her.
Just that moment
knowing she was back
and knowing the
capacity that she was back in
was just, it was
just really cool.
We were all just so happy.
People that hadn't met
her before were confused
but knew that it
was a special moment
so definitely the
favorite moment for Claude.
- I was on HR for
a little over a year
when Claude joined the team.
And it was the best day
ever when she did. (laughs)
- [Claude] So all my experiences
I think throughout the years
and throughout studying
and psychology and spirituality
and all these things kind
of started to create this soup,
kind of this minestrone soup of
being passionate about people.
Wanting to unlock people.
Wanting to facilitate
growth and change with people
and yet I was a strategist.
I was understanding
human behavior
and how I could
sell more toothpaste.
I knew how I could
sell more toilet paper.
I understood how I could
bring peace of mind
to a mom in Italy
with spaghetti sauce.
But I needed more and more
experiences working with people
to understand how we all
dive in the pool together.
Who swims this way,
who swims that way,
who's drowning,
all of that stuff.
So, that's a long-winded
way of saying that
it took me a short
lifetime to get here.
- [Justin] Claude's such a
hybrid of understanding
the business needs because she's
already a king of that trade,
a master of that trade,
but she's also a master of
reading people like Gary is.
Those two, along with several
other people in this agency,
can walk into a room,
read what's going on
and understand what to do next
in the middle of a conversation.
- [Claude] When I left Vayner,
the reason I left was
because all I wanted to do,
all I wanted to do
was be with people.
Build relationships, coach,
I thought that
maybe I would start
my own coaching
practice at 47 years old.
I thought maybe I would
go back to school and
get my master's in social work.
I didn't know that I'd end
up as a Chief Heart Officer.
I love it. It makes
so much sense.
So much sense.
But throughout all those years,
I learned what listening does,
I learned what empathy does,
I learned that you absolutely
need to take up space.
You deserve to take up space.
If you've been invited
to that meeting,
you're there for a
reason, so speak.
I believe in people and I see
the good in the every day.
I build teams rooted
in a generosity of spirit
and a belief in possibility.
I unlock people so that they
can become their own champions
and I celebrate the little
as well as the big victories.
I believe that there's
magic in every moment
and that people need
to be allowed to dream.
Truly I believe in that
glimmer in a teammate's eyes
and I know how to
push that glimmer until
it becomes a full-blown smile.
But there's a give and take,
there's a dance and
I think in all of these years
I've learned what
that dance is about and
now I'm at a place
where I get to work
with 700 people-plus
every single day.
I get to work like that with Gary
and I get to work and grow
and foster an amazing
team that's just hungry.
They're just sponges.
So it took a long
time but I'm here and
I wouldn't be any other place.
- It's also so awesome to
have a CEO and to have a boss
who truly cares about
the people within the walls.
And I think that's
what makes coming to work
so worth it and so awesome.
- You know, Claude is
one of the few individuals
that I've ever met in my life that
makes me feel the way I feel
and so to create this position
which is more than Mark,
more than AJ,
more than James, more than Scott,
more than Segal or Mickey,
to create a position
that really is me, right?
The scalable version
of what I do with you guys
one-on-one in those meetings
and have the autonomy
to make decisions
that make no sense on paper
but make a whole
lot of sense on heart.
I want to build
the best, greatest,
let me rephrase,
we (audience laughter)
we want to build the single
greatest human organization
in the history of times.
- [Claude] So when I think
people are meeting with me
it's not to get Gary.
They can get Gary.
His door in completely
open and he's available.
I think they're looking for
why am I here.
I think a lot of times
people ask me what I do here.
How did I get here?
They're interested in
why an old fogie like me is
running around with
a bunch of Millennials.
I don't know but
I complement him,
I believe,
by coming at situations
in a slightly different way.
Some times more emotional,
some times more heartfelt.
Some times with a little
bit more vinegar than honey.
Some times calling
them on their bullshit
in a different
way than he might.
And some times I know
that he's had a conversation
with them which has been honey
so I'll come in and look at it
with a slightly different slant
to help someone or
assist someone in getting
A, to the answer or the answer
that we'd like them to get to.
On another level, I might
need one answer for him
or he might need to
tell me one adjective
and I know exactly the direction
I need to take a conversation.
Gary and I speak all the time.
We're in constant communication.
And actually, we're
two sides of the same coin.
In lockstep when it
comes to heart and hustle.
I mean, we're really focused on
creating the greatest
Honey Empire of all time.
What I've learned
from working with Gary is
a completely
different level of patience.
A completely different
level of accountability.
A completely
different level of humility.
I've learned to let go of
the 99% of stuff
that you don't need
and really focus on
that number 1% North Star.
Together, Gary and I,
marry the heart and the hustle.
I create the strategic
direction for all things people
alongside Gary who creates
the strategic vision
for all things business.
And together with our team
we are building the
greatest Honey Empire.
Fueled by people operating
at the top of their game.
Simply put, I'm in
the people business.
I touch anything and everything
that has to do with the people
at VaynerMedia
and their experiences.